all right yo blue light cat podcast
bootleg kev show
211 is here yeah my god my god welcome
welcome man
it's crazy i think i've met you
originally in about 2010 when i was
doing radio in vegas
yeah we met the day remember jeezy had a
show
at the pearl um freddy opened
nah see that was that had to be way that
had to be uh
because i met you with fred you met me
with you man we were freddie when we did
the um
i had to be that was 2012 going yeah
that was 2011 going on 2012. he had a
show
we went from vegas tucson
vegas i mean we went to phoenix tucson
vegas and then back to la
and that's what i i met you in phoenix i
think you put all
three four shows together i put a couple
shows together for fred in phoenix but
i'm telling you i met you at the pearl
i'm pretty sure were you at that show i
probably was though
yeah you think jeezy was doing in vegas
or yeah i'm saying
at the same time i was there yeah yeah
yeah so um
you know for people who don't know man
you you've been a staple in la for a
long time
um you got your store the level up store
that's booming and you know you've been
an artist for how long have you been
like when did you first start releasing
music
first started releasing music was 2007.
yeah and then 2008 was kind of like i
was solidified like man that's an artist
right right right and then i really
learned how to rap 2009
you feel me in 2010 has just been
learning how to dig the game
you know what was your like the first
person who kind of got behind you and
co-signed you
in l.a i was on death row before i met
jeezy you know what i mean and then the
whole [ __ ] he got getting shot
you know what i'm saying he like
disappeared and you know he had his own
[ __ ] going on so
you know how'd that go um i remember
jeezy called in like man if that [ __ ]
don't work over there
come on through so you signed what what
year did you sign
were you what year did you meet suga and
start rolling with him i met suga in
2005.
oh wow through my homie my big homie uh
peewee rest in peace so i mean you know
just like every [ __ ] in l.a everybody
rap you know i mean so
i was making you know uh freestyles in
the garage putting them on cds and
giving them to my homies so
i was a rapper in my neighborhood you
know what i'm saying that's
you know coming up and then one day my
my homie was like um yeah you know i i
know somebody that i was in the fez with
shook potne and we told him about you we
gonna
whatever so we i'm in vegas one day and
they like sugar the strip club the crazy
horse so we pull up with my homies
you know and i introduced myself he's
like yeah we just took it from there and
come to l.a start recording i had songs
of tupac and
[ __ ] i never heard him ever i walked out
the studio but yeah
he first person to put me in the big
boys studio um
yeah put the mic closer to your face so
we can hear you better yeah he's the
first one to put me in the big boys
studio
um that's when petey pablo was over
there
i remember when petey pablo was on that
was a very weird
situation but [ __ ] you know it never
made sense to me
nah nah he thought he was tupac or
something like this
yeah because there was like that era um
when
it was that double xl cover with corrupt
yeah that was way before that he first
got out right and so you met him kind of
like that kind of
2005. so that had kind of already fallen
apart and he hadn't had yeah yeah
i think um really when i started hanging
out over there
corrupt was over there so i kind of met
suge
when corrupt was there you know i mean
because i used to hang with roscoe and
tone all hawaii
remember little brother of course roscoe
roscoe was so fired
that was hard on the intro on streets as
a mother
bro come on that's what made me want to
ride corrupt and when i was
who's that song called
he set the whole it was track one he set
the whole tone for the rest of the
project
i remember thinking like yo roscoe's
next and then i didn't even know that
[ __ ] was my age though
i'm like damn that fooled my age when i
first met i'm like we the same age
he caught that smith yo he caught that
smooth sailing record and i was like oh
it's over i don't remember that but then
he was on girls all
paws he was on girls all paws roscoe was
cool
so you were hanging out with the white
dude but i wasn't rapping though right
so that kind of gave me the motivation
of [ __ ] man i'm hanging with these and
he's every day they could do it i could
do it
you know what i mean but i always was in
the cut trying to write or trying to put
it together you know what i'm saying
and um yeah so when i guess when that
kind of fell apart everything over there
you know this
dismantled it came about like two more
years later
and then i just fell in but i never
really like introduced a one-on-one with
suge
like i'm you know i'm saying whooping
duh
you know what i mean but um about 2005
came around and i introduced myself
and we had our one on one and then he
started coming telling me to come to the
studio how do you think like how would
you describe suge as a person
based on your relationship with nothing
as as
everybody think he is he's just a big
old cool [ __ ] to me
he one of the coolest [ __ ] i ever met
because we hear all this crazy [ __ ] and
then you hear people who like really
know him and they're like man
suga's one of the realest like one of
the realest coolest [ __ ]
one of the i mean the stories he'll tell
you you feel me to even sit
sit in a circle and listen to these
stories he'll tell you and it's just
like yeah
so after after watching after knowing
him and then watching all these
[ __ ] weird-ass shits that they got on
tv about
tupac and biggie and shook this and
shook that i'd be like damn that's
they just got the whole [ __ ] on top of
suge it's just like
yeah there's all this they drag his name
through the mud like that you know i
feel like
in that situation with the tupac biggie
situation obviously both of them dying
there had to be you gotta you gotta
figure out who the bad guy is and the
public
made suge the bad guy in there yeah
because
because there was nobody there i mean
look both murders are still inside
the angel exactly they made puffy an
angel but now it's coming out like he
was really
on the same type of [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying like some of this [ __ ] man
it's like damn [ __ ] 25 years later it's
like you was on the same type of [ __ ]
you got
crips with i just found that out like
you had to come to crips with you bro
like you knew what you was doing like
come on man
yes some of the uh stuff that like i
remember there was a la times article
that came out about puffy maybe like
eight nine years ago and it was like oh
yeah you talking you popping [ __ ] again
we don't again we don't know
i mean at least i don't know yeah i mean
there's people who
think they know exactly what happened on
each side right yeah but it's it's
interesting i mean i'm not
sure i was definitely the bad guy yeah
yeah yeah sugar was paying as the bad
guy
and made it seem like [ __ ] was
bullying puffy and biggie and [ __ ] like
that but
i mean it's just like it's the same [ __ ]
going on now it's just like
i got out of town [ __ ] come out here
and you know what i mean get with some
get with a [ __ ] like me or somebody or
another homie and
get the gang banging but it's just on a
different platform because you're this
big ass rap star you know what i mean so
it's
it's like i mean it's
like the culture is the la culture
i've been everywhere everybody want to
be a la [ __ ] everybody loved this
culture
crips bloods man the [ __ ] walk and all
this [ __ ]
is just uh it's just i don't
i can't even explain it but we influence
the rest of the
america the rest of the world feel me
really
it's just something about l.a culture
you know the gang [ __ ]
and the way we stand i was we was at the
restaurant yesterday and the homies from
chicago like yeah i gotta i gotta
put my feet like this and be like yeah
what's up i'm like that's that's just
this is it's funny
but it's crazy that this is how the rest
of the people think of
us you know but they like it though you
know what i'm saying well i mean i was
talking to big you and i was like you
know before he went to prison
uh i was like yo before you went to
prison like like he was in prison when
the peak of gangbanging became like
commercial
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying like
you remember back in the day there was
like a crips versus bloods album and
like yeah that's my
one of my favorite albums banging on wax
ain't one two
and then they went from dhamma riders to
nationwide riders
right so like there was that that point
in time when
the gang [ __ ] became so cool in the 90s
colors came out or like i think that was
late 80s early 90s
but like it became just like a worldwide
thing and that's
i think like you said like just la
influence in the world as far as like
there's crips and
sets and bloods brother the the kid on
empire dusty locain is talking
neighborhood [ __ ] [ __ ] he's from
brooklyn
that's crazy right it's insane but it's
just like how to um
i tell you i just like i tell everybody
else
to define why [ __ ] gang bang
everywhere else
all you gotta do is listen to summer
vacation from ice cube all these is not
even gang [ __ ] saying
[ __ ] out of town ain't gang banging
there's just from a gang
right they're just gang members they're
not this is not their culture
it's just something for them to do
what's the like give me because p for
people who are watching this drug gangs
that's what i'm saying like give me that
so when you say gang banging
um what is that like banging is like
we're gonna
we're gonna wake up today we're gonna go
put in some work on
feel me like if you're blood you're
gonna go shoot some crips or you're
gonna go beat up some crips or you
riding around to go
find these people you know vice versa
and then i feel like
i feel like i'm gonna say all the out of
town people but
a lot of people from out of town that's
not like you'll be from 60s but
you've never been on 60th street y'all
don't have a 60th street in your
neighborhood
you know what i'm saying this is saying
they from pyruvate like you ain't
like you feel me i woke up in
[ __ ] kansas somewhere you know what
i'm saying well y'all just like ice
cubes say they just dying
and banging over streets that they ain't
never heard of you feel me or been to
or so it's like they waking up
and they just claiming the gang and
claiming the [ __ ] but it's like the good
the good parts that come with it but
like you ain't really
not really he's not here for that part
for the bad part not taking this bad
part but don't get it
wrong like i've been in the places where
[ __ ] is really gangbanging and putting
got their own gangs in their own
neighborhoods uh
prime example [ __ ] uh macon georgia
them is out there like 1994 out there
and one players got their own gang their
own section
they own name they and they doing it how
we do it out here it's just it's
different so i can't say everybody but a
lot of the majority
is just it's just different you know
what i'm saying yeah
um i do think that like because
people will not understand what it means
to get banged on yeah yeah
and it's like dj head had to educate me
when i moved out here and be like hey
look
yeah like you know you like i know
you're like dude he gave me the whole
hat run down he was like look at the
t-hat
on you what does this happen it mean it
mean gangster [ __ ]
basically it's crazy i mean and it's
blue so i literally i got this happening
in trouble me and freddie we were in
austin texas
and i bought this hat yeah yeah yeah but
we ain't we're in l.a now no i know
i know so so it's crazy get rough bro
bro head had to give me the whole
breakdown he's like look bro you can't
wear yankees hats
unless you're in the valley no he's like
he's like astro hat's out
yeah he's like he gave me the whole [ __ ]
and i was like [ __ ] i was telling my i
was telling less i was you know last
people think you're a [ __ ] hoover
well yeah we don't care if you're an
astro fan or not you gotta leave that
[ __ ] somewhere else bro cause
we gonna spin off and [ __ ] gonna get on
you where are you from check it out all
that
that's when
well you better just get out the way or
you feel me it's where they get bad
yeah it's wild because like i was like
well look i'm from arizona what about a
diamondbacks hat he's like i think
you're good with that
he's like that and just a plain l.a you
might wake up in a bad mood and you
could have a
[ __ ] you got the a hat on he could
have that [ __ ] don't even mean nothing
that [ __ ] might just be like homie what
that a stand for like just because he in
a bad mood like bro
you be like best so what [ __ ] all that
you feel me take that [ __ ] off and the
[ __ ] be really in
you know what i'm saying on a bad day
hey hey head told me he was like look if
anyone ever tries to bang on you
just start acting super pissed off like
you just got into a fight with your girl
man [ __ ] this business [ __ ] just left
me here i'm waiting for my uber i'm
gonna kill this
head gonna get you [ __ ] up you're
about to tell the [ __ ] man i'm
not from here
you feel me i'm not from over here i'm
from i'm from
arizona but like a [ __ ] like
all right all right
you know what i'm saying am i out of
town pilots be coming here and they'd be
like man i can't wear red i can't wear
blue
like bro all you got to do is speak you
sound like you from florida or something
like man ain't nobody worried about you
but it's only in these sections like
certain areas we're in north hollywood
bro you know i'm not i could walk down
the street ain't nobody finna say
nothing you know what i'm saying but if
you're in
certain areas south of [ __ ] wilshire
or some [ __ ] like that
really southpaw um when you pass [ __ ]
um
what is that [ __ ] like olympic let's go
south of the olympics
make sure you it's you can get banged on
me you will be at the 7-eleven the gas
station yeah
all that burger spots you know that's
that's where it goes up at
the mall right you know what i mean so
being around sugar what's like the
what's your craziest suge night story
man that you that that you were around
um because that was an interesting like
time of suggs
because when did when did he get into um
get into it with the barber dude
remember there was the barber that
punched him oh yeah with greg i went to
school with that [ __ ] i know him too
yeah that was um that was like i was
like probably 2010
yeah something like that yeah one big
one
yeah people still wearing big clothes i
remember that yeah when people were
still wearing big clothes i remember
that
yeah uh i was in atlanta when that
happened
and um yeah so i wasn't around for that
what was the crazy [ __ ] you were around
with should um
man i can't even really put my put my
finger on it it's just we balled out
really like every time i'm with him
we're balling out
i remember okay i remember one time
though well really like when i first
started [ __ ] with him
i'm on uh i'm in um lake tahoe
right i'm on a little vacation and [ __ ]
so he called me out of nowhere it's when
the chirps was out yeah
yeah he like yeah hey what you doing i'm
like man i'm chilling
like i come to the studio right now but
i got these girls with me though
you know what i mean so i'm like bro i'm
in lake tahoe no no before that i'm like
i feel like you try to play me on the
speakerphone in front of these [ __ ]
you feel me so i'm like
i'm like hey homie you feel me [ __ ] i
ain't
all i'm thinking is the snoop dogg and
the back in the day [ __ ] how
i'm like bro this this ain't that [ __ ]
power rule [ __ ] hold up
he like man chill out bro just come to
the studio [ __ ] i'm gonna pay for
everything
i'm like yeah all right but i was lowkey
embarrassed because he like [ __ ] drop
everything come to the studio right now
and really heard it that's all i heard
was or else yeah but he didn't say that
though but that's what you heard that's
what i heard like
or else like hold up who you think you
talked to you feel me
but uh so i'm like alright i'm current
studio
now i went i remember i drove to reno
they dropped me off the arena i put my
whole vacation on pause
fly out here just to record like four
songs you know what i'm saying and
he cashed me out like i heard about a
thousand right my ticket was only like
250 round trip or something like that
put me in the hotel and all i'm like
bawling you feel me he had the suitcase
the briefcase opened the briefcase up
and he had all this money in the
briefcase i saw this thing really rich
rich huh
he was just moving he was still moving
around like [ __ ] he was moving around
like sugar and he's thought he was broke
and all that like man
he had a new porsche the new the newest
cars out
living in century city uh plaza whatever
that [ __ ] called over there and he
living
he lived here at the top in the
penthouse you know
there i think there was like a obviously
the public perception of sugars he was
like
this huge blood that was like ran l.a
but look when we walked through so so
everybody would hate on him but when we
walked through the palms or
we'd be in vegas it'd be it'd be like
hella white people like
oh can i get a picture we love you and
italian like i'll be like damn they like
you get love but
[ __ ] will walk off and be like
[ __ ] suga he killed tupac and he did
this and he did that and he's a murderer
and all this
a woman beat her and all that i'm like
this nigga's like the coolest [ __ ] in
the world though
all right you know what i mean that's
crazy the game and all that too
um so from the death row situation is
how you ended up working with jeezy
after that
yes so um yeah so i was already hanging
out in
in atlanta and [ __ ] and you know um
hanging with
um i had a friend that was i work with
jeezy
they introduced me and all that so at
the time i'm like yeah you know i'm
[ __ ] with sugar trying to do my rap
[ __ ] and all that i go hang with them
and he just told me you know when if
that don't work out you know you got a
home over here
like all right so when it didn't work
out i started hanging out over there
with them
right going to the promo tours and and
then
and it just turned into it took me like
a year to get signed over there
a tt yeah yeah so yeah i think like
that was like a cool i think that was a
cool moment because at the time
obviously
jeezy was putting out hella mixed tapes
uh
and then i feel like it was kind of like
cte's second run kind of
because this was the first run no no i
feel like i feel like 2010 2011 was kind
of like nah i got signed over there in
2007.
oh [ __ ] yeah so this was so this was the
first run
oh yeah that's the first run yeah yeah
that's the first one sign the cte def
jam so i was on the label deal
oh so yeah yeah i don't know why i
thought you you signed over there like
early to 2010's no i was there before
i was there before freddie okay no i'm
saying so i was like one of the first
artists over there was slick pulling
blood right right and then they put out
the
rocket came okay yeah yeah and rocky and
them already had a relationship but then
me and rocket got like this because
from out here so it was just a look you
know what i'm saying and
um and then yeah i should start putting
out music and then i think freddie got
there in 2010
yep but i already knew freddie from out
here uh jayrock introduced me to freddie
the first night we met we did a song
after the club
one night you know what i mean and we've
just been cool ever since
yeah it's crazy because um
didn't did you leave you left cte
after fred right it was around it was
before
so freddie got there and um
what was that the beginning of 2010 i
left and
now he got there beginning at 2000 left
yeah 2010. it was like 2010 2011 this
year yeah
and i left like in the public i left in
like 12 but i was already gone from
a little money situation like the end of
2011.
you know what i mean yeah it's crazy
because obviously
um you and fred have kept a relationship
for so long
despite a situation like that might
you know people kind of choose up you
know what i'm saying no they chose up on
me and that's the only reason why i
[ __ ] with freddie so tough because he
was the only [ __ ] that stayed
down with me like in my even when i met
you that time only reason i went on that
tour
because i had he knew that i was leaving
the ct situation they [ __ ] me over
like 400 000.
so i'm like man [ __ ] these [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying and i have a big
enough microphone to go and just be
dissing because it's going to make me
look better so i'm like man i'ma just do
what i'm going to do
you know what i'm saying and um and
everybody like bailed on me and i had so
much slander i was going through much so
much [ __ ] at the time
you know um that everybody bailed on me
he was the only one that was like bro
still he like that's how i came to
arizona he's like bro you got to get out
of that last yeah
it's [ __ ] you got a lot of [ __ ] going
on right now come on tour with me
and i remember that i'm like bro bring
my gun and all that [ __ ] like nah
i ain't telling you don't bring it but
right right now you ain't gonna need it
you know what i'm saying like [ __ ] for
a rap concert like shoot me
you feel me ain't gonna need no pistol
or not no protection you're like no it's
not like that
yeah it's crazy because i know fred's
side of what happened at
uh at cte um and it seems as if
a lot of the people almost everyone who
was around jeezy early on is not there
anymore nobody [ __ ] with that [ __ ] and
no and nobody's got anything good to say
about
and i've met jeezy a bunch but you know
even like uh
shout out to car you know carbon 15 15
is you know that's that was my guy who
was
you know anytime i needed anything jesus
related i would hit 15. you know what
i'm saying yeah
and obviously about the 15 we still be
great business real dude
he's still i still talking about
everybody over there damn near like
puller just got out
i spoke to him uh briefly um but like me
freddy i talked to kink all the time
what do you think um i mean you were
around jeezy
a lot longer than fred so you know you
were around that whole situation yeah
he was like man why ain't tell me i'm
like bro what i look like i can't tell i
didn't bring you in the situation i
would have been like
you feel me this ain't it bro this ain't
gonna happen you knew it wasn't it
pretty soon pretty quick or i knew it
wasn't it when he when they
appeared on the bus and i'm like what
you doing here bro he like man i'm
coming from the sign over here and i'm
like oh we're going to see i double
a and um they like you know him i'm like
yeah that's
just the homie what you mean hey like
he's from gary i'm like this [ __ ]
living in l.a bro like we
got songs together and everything okay
cool i would never mad at freddy i'm
looking at jeezy like [ __ ] you bringing
new artists in and you can't even you
can't even work the articles you've had
on your label for that
yeah [ __ ] in debt and some most [ __ ]
we don't have no music
like what's going on you know what i'm
saying and
so i ain't gonna i think i think one day
he was just like um
the way i left was he caught this big
old meeting and [ __ ] was like yeah i'm
not giving no money out which
was giving no money out in the first
place and he like uh
you know [ __ ] gotta gotta go out and
use the name and the label to get money
so i'm like that's what i did you know
what i mean and i went and got a
four hundred thousand dollar deal for
some music half the music that was
already out
and half was unreleased music and the
[ __ ] sent me assistant deceased
i was with smc so he told you
i think he told me to go do this and
then he went to do it
he hit you with the season decisions
[ __ ] your papers [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] up
and i'm getting your artist money
i could've just pocketed all of this
[ __ ] myself and been like [ __ ] y'all
you know i mean and and from that point
on i'm like bro
they had me fool like this family first
and this family [ __ ] i was gonna say
like based on your
you were around jeezy i guess probably
when he was transitioning out of
being uh known as like a really hardcore
gangster rapper into him kind of
becoming more of a staple in him i was
there for
so i met him today um
the day thug motivation went gold in
vegas
wow you know i mean and then i was with
them damn near
all-time great album yeah i know not
that yeah that was a great album
all the way up until what the 103
or some [ __ ] like that yes because i was
going to say like
i think that people from the outside
look in him will be like look well jeezy
obviously has grown
into who he is today
right and you could say whatever you
want to say i just saw the interview
with the his old partner
um that was on the yeah and where he was
like look that
versus scratching any any street cred he
could ever have
a mystery yeah i don't know what he was
thinking with that yeah
but um i know he was thinking it's a
look they could do anything
for a look you know he's hosting the
[ __ ] talk show like i think jesus
thirsty right now he's he reaching he
thirsty he don't know what to do [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] with
him he ain't got no real [ __ ] with him
were you uh around when the
the the gucci beef was pretty pretty
serious
um it was always serious but
you know um should i know i actually ran
into gucci
one time i ran into i ran into all them
on my own time
you know out here like what's happening
wakka too and me and wakka we cool like
that's that's the homie right
ran into waka we chopped it up 2010
months later i run into gucci in my
studio remember that
yeah me and gucci chopped it up he was
so cool i'm like damn bro i
don't like this [ __ ] you feel me gucci
was cool as [ __ ]
and um and yes
but then i've been in clubs and we was
all together and
ain't nothing happened you know what i'm
saying so i i was confused but well
that's what fred was telling me he'd be
like man like
i'm like friends the type of
[ __ ] if we got problems we in
the same place something's gonna happen
bro that's what i was confused we'd be
in central station and then [ __ ] be
right over there and i'm like okay well
let's get it wasn't there there was a um
when the mmg beef got kind of
i was gone already oh you're already
gone okay okay okay okay
yeah yeah i was there i was i think all
that [ __ ] was over a [ __ ]
that's what i heard honestly really
because i was there
all that [ __ ] around when did the bmf
come out
um the song that was uh 2010 right 10
yep 2010 yeah
all that that time when that [ __ ] came
out
and it was basically it seemed like it
was over a [ __ ] in that in that song
you feel me [ __ ] was mad i don't know
if he felt like he should have made that
song to get that
you know what i mean but who cares so it
was just a whole bunch of
weird [ __ ] going on but i was cool with
ross ross gave me a verse
all kind of [ __ ] like i'm like you know
what i'm saying but then i left in the
midst of all that you know what i mean
and they had to figure that [ __ ] out
damn did you notice like a change um
with jeezy's energy just like over time
like because like if you were around in
07 i feel like that was kind of gz
probably still
moving a certain way with a certain type
of people around him you know what i'm
saying
yeah yeah i mean a lot of people was
just he ended up getting that def jam
situation
which was was that that was later right
uh he was already he was always on death
jam no i mean i mean
atlantic or the atlantic
i was gone by the end yeah so yeah it's
just like you'll hear some people who
are around gz like super early
and they'll be like yeah [ __ ] was like
real out like it was some real [ __ ]
going on and then
you know i mean it was active it was
some active [ __ ] going on we didn't got
into some [ __ ] before and it was real
activity
i can't knock that but just on some
loyalty and business [ __ ]
it wasn't it wasn't solid which explains
why nobody [ __ ] with him no more and
it's just like and then look and like i
think
like again like i'm a fan of jeezy i've
been around him he's a nice guy i'm
there i don't have any personal issues
with him but just like from a fan's
perspective you'll look at like cte and
you'll be like dang no one ever came out
of cte
and you could say he had he had guys but
you could say
yg but yg was already on def jam and
they kind of just threw the cte through
it and then
yeah i think that kind of got in his ear
about that [ __ ] but i left in the midst
of that like the whole yg going on
i told i told jeezy i said man it's the
guy he finna be the next [ __ ] up
well we was in colony i'm like and i
told just incredible we unplug drama
computer and plug just incredible up
because we're telling drama playoff yg
[ __ ] like who is that i'm like what
[ __ ]
unplug this [ __ ] bro plug in just
incredible [ __ ] up man play that yg [ __ ]
i'm texting my boy to text him tell him
what songs to play
i'm telling him in jeezy ear it's my
birthday too so i'm drunk you're feeling
like
i need that now that [ __ ] no watch i'm
telling watch how does this club turn
around he played one joint boom play
another joint boom no the crowd
that the club just turned up from there
i'm like well it's the [ __ ] if paru
young homie he got like a situation at
def jam i don't think they know what to
do with it you need to pull these
strings bring them over here he's like
yeah well this [ __ ]
ain't got fun to get up my chain [ __ ]
we finna come over here and
uh no no hold on hold on hold up but i'm
telling this [ __ ] like he's the guy bro
this is because we had a condo in in
atlanta
every morning i'm waking up playing yg
nipsey you know what i'm saying the [ __ ]
that i
that we listen to out here and they like
are you playing that [ __ ] i'm like what
you mean this is the [ __ ] that we
playing in l.a this is what's going on
yeah and um and i leave 30 days after
that we fall out
30 60 days after that and then i
remember
i remember um some mixtapes coming out
you know what i mean and then we i hear
them on songs and taking pictures i'm
like okay he didn't rant
it's happening it's cool though i never
was like mad about it or not like that
you know what i'm saying
and it just turned into what it turned
into hey
i know you're watching the interview
right now thank you for watching we got
to interrupt this for a special
uh announcement from our good good good
sponsors over at odd socks
i have all socks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssoxofficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at nico
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssoxofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving is they got the
naruto
and i'm not even into that [ __ ] but the
socks are fly and the street fighter
socks
crazy licenses odd socks official dot
com keyword
bootleg kev right now save 20 off at
checkout what did you think uh when you
saw the versus thing
did you like like what are your thoughts
on it
played itself you think so played itself
every step of the way like for what you
sell no records like that don't nobody
even know you had adam come out and you
did all this just to
[ __ ] on to people i was sliding with you
like
you know mack town [ __ ] basically yeah
i mean look look i
mean the guy that died you know what i'm
saying and in gucci showed his ass
so yeah i think i think when gucci
started getting disrespectful
man gucci been disrespectful no no but
i'm saying like i know gucci was going
to be disrespectful
yes on instagram he came out
swinging with a whole original new song
no that wasn't new
i thought that first song was a new song
that song was this is gucci mane
verse geez that [ __ ] was out when state
strap came out
we was watching these views we was
watching this feud from out here
i didn't know them when this happened
and then i kind of fell over there like
and it was already going on really gucci
was in jail when i got signed over there
so
so let me ask you this because i think
like the other side of the coin is like
well
jeezy's showing people that
you know you can grow [ __ ] all that you
know growing cause
the homie rest in peace can't grow you
feel me right
you doing all this for what now you
didn't sh you didn't try to [ __ ] on this
[ __ ] your whole career and his whole
career
what's the use of y'all patching up like
i feel you
you know that's cool but like come on
man you didn't don't [ __ ] on this but
let me ask you this don't you think if
you're in jeezy's
um all that [ __ ] was for look no no i
feel you
he thought it was going to work because
originally it was supposed to be jeezy
versus ti
yeah but he man of course you got this
that's why we're talking about it now he
did that be
i don't know what makes him i think you
think of like where jeezy probably is in
life he's got kids in college he just
got married
he's definitely all the way out of that
side of the you know
so we don't even know if who he is then
because this whole time we've been
knowing this person
you feel me yeah i think when someone
loses their life because of a situation
is when
you didn't even it couldn't even i'm not
saying you had to go do nothing but you
didn't have to do this
right like it's all raguchi already on
top he's the guy so let me ask you this
though tell me do you think
that alone if somebody sees what
happened with gizzy and gucci and they
in their personal situations with
somebody in this because i think that
that's
uh something that's so hard about
stopping some of this violence right
because
how are you gonna tell me to not do this
to somebody when my cousin's dead over
this [ __ ] or you know my
partner or whoever and it's been so long
like you just brought
more [ __ ] out of the closet that was
already kind of like
you know it was calm down but do you
think yeah i mean i i mean
do you but do you think that there's
some good that could have came out of
that whether it was maybe influencing
somebody who watched the verses
i mean i feel like it was some good that
they did the song at the end and you
know it's cool
ain't nobody get shot or fight or
nothing like that you kind of showed a
little
but deep down the only reason we know
these people is because
of these situations and the people that
you claim to be
right that you've been telling us that
you are and who we fell in love with
and at the end of the day it's like i
don't think jeezy's been that guy for a
long time though as far as just like the
persona he even the persona he gives out
to everyone yeah but
but we give it the benefit of the doubt
to be like you steal the guy
from thug motivation and all these other
inspiration
and you know you're still somewhat of
that guy right right now when you go
against everything that you've
told us who you are it's like now we
lost all
faith in you you know what i mean street
wise and this is who you built your [ __ ]
on this is
why jesus jeezy is because of who you
are and what you've been doing you know
what i mean so i don't know
i don't know you know what i mean but i
know the people i'll be around and the
type of people i'll be with
they just like feeling that [ __ ] yeah
just on the street side i feel like yeah
like that i don't even have to do that
you know i think i just think that
both there's like the street side of the
coin where it's like yeah like come on
someone died you don't ever do that
and then there's like hey look well
obviously jeezy hasn't been
that guy for so long but it don't even
mean
if you're that guy now you didn't
brought all these extra feelings up that
was already
like that man that's rest in peace he
got a kid he's got it he got a son
you know i mean he got family and all
that gucci over here talking about
smoking on that packing
come on that gucci is the biggest [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying all you did was
you you you put gucci like this
you shoulda you man you you shoulda just
retired bro when you said you was gonna
retire three four years ago
like we don't we don't need all this
extra [ __ ] you think you're trying to do
go get married
go with your girl and all that y'all go
do what y'all doing get out the way
basically you're in the way bro get out
the way you know what i'm saying that's
fair
uh yeah yeah i i thought from just from
a fans perspective i obviously and i was
watching that [ __ ] in the dark
like what the [ __ ] bro you let that ride
you down
and you come out with the bmf shirt on
and all that like man
[ __ ] don't even like you bro like what
you trying to do you feel me
i don't understand this uw he was
reaching
you know what i'm saying so yeah
whatever um so you got your new album
out
uh masterchef which is it's like
is it eight or nine songs um eight songs
a song
yeah um it feels like a you and freddie
joint project
i mean yeah it's really basically right
basically yeah
you know he's not on two of them uh yeah
he
yeah he only owns six racks he's on six
out of eight yeah yeah
um and i was hitting you later
so album is fire good looking good look
yeah
what like obviously you and fred's
relationship is so strong
um he's had such a crazy i mean he's
been on his run forever
yeah yeah
yeah i ain't surprised i think he came
out of that um jail situation
was just crazy i think too
the fact that we were i think you know i
told people like uh the pandemic
made it made the world listen to rap
music differently yeah because we ain't
standing on couches
yeah yeah we ain't at the club popping
bottles
now you listening in your headphones
yeah or you listening in the car in the
car
and so when you listen that way you're
like it's a different way of listening
to the music right so that's when it's
like you see those grammy nominations
and it's royce the five
nines i never thought of it like that
and it's nice and
it's like oh [ __ ] it's a lot of real rap
[ __ ] rap rap [ __ ]
yeah and you know fred fred went from
bandana to
man to alfredo right now i don't know
for sure but i just mean like
2019 to 2020 he's like crazy but like
how dope has it been to like just watch
his last
year two years [ __ ] it's it's it's
inspiring
i'd be motivated you know i mean um
yeah it's you go crazy when your friends
just motivate you i ain't got to go look
at no strangers you know i can
go around the corner to the house and
he'll he'll bust a rap play
like damn you just did that okay then go
in the studio and rap
like he just dropped that [ __ ] he
probably like fo-fi songs in on a new
project already i'm gonna go over that
later
he recorded like the day or two days
after the grammys
yeah and it's already out video shot
yeah we shot the video like um
oh you was there i was there i pulled up
for a second and then my wife was my
wife was banging on me so i was like
guys i was like look i gotta go yeah so
he worked work so that'd be inspiring me
you know i mean that [ __ ]
even if he like this you know i'm saying
i'm right here and i'm trying to get
there i gotta work at least twice as
hard as he is to get to
where he at you know what i'm saying so
did you ever consider because i feel
like you've
you know you opened your store um and
you've kind of like helped with some
younger artists
um have you ever gotten to the point
where you're like yo
i'm gonna do this rap [ __ ] for fun if it
works out cool but like you're um
i feel like i've just noticed you more
as like doing [ __ ] doing community
[ __ ] doing like you know what i mean
like
and then like we get an album from you
and it's like oh [ __ ] yeah
this [ __ ] i think i think everything is
built from the music
you know everything comes from the music
that's what perico be telling me all the
time he like yeah man you know we gonna
do this this this
but everything everything starts here
it's the music we can do all this
because it is even the reason that i can
bring people to the store well i got
this big
this this [ __ ] franchise i mean not
franchise but this uh
landmark restaurant next door to me
right but that's like maybe 45 50
of my clientele and the other people you
bring to other people is
from rap music from instagram from who i
am
because they're like oh [ __ ] we got to
go to this store all of this is from the
rap
you know what i mean but i can fall back
on the rap and i can still stay relevant
because of the story and the [ __ ] that
i'm throwing and i could bring the
younger
artists in and have pop-ups and i could
still be the guy and bust these moves
and stay relevant
with content without even dropping music
but it still all
revolves back to the music you know it's
all gonna come back to the music
so i gotta keep dropping you know what i
mean and it's just the passion
and the checks that's gonna come every
month it's like [ __ ] on my mind residual
income might as well keep running
low and yeah keep on rapping and
dropping because it's easy
right this is when you think so [ __ ]
hard just like what we were saying about
those other artists mm-hmm
like you can't be sitting here waiting
nine years to drop a project talking
about man like how to get my money right
i gotta i got it i i mean it's prime
examples of some
certain artists i i've watched it you
they need no money
you need no money like like really
somebody's gucci and him
man ruchi worked instead of money he
worked
right out hustled everybody studio
five studio sessions a day busting
versus down here
he didn't have to spend no money because
he he just outworked everybody now ruchi
um
i wanted to get to ruchi because uh you
know you part of his
his come up um ruchi i think the first
record i heard of his was the lean like
a cholo [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
damn he was just getting up on him on
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was crazy
dallas played me that oh yeah yeah that
was crazy and uh
i was like oh this [ __ ] is yeah tight
like someone remixed
yeah yeah that record you know but uh
how did you how did you meet ruchi and
like kind of what's your involvement
with roruchi because obviously he's on
youtube
um daddy is my big homie like
big taco my big homie he raised me in
the streets from when i was like 13
you know what i'm saying until [ __ ] he
went to jail you know what i mean so
now he's in mexico right yeah he in
mexico now he got deported
so so i've known ruchi and angels since
they was little babies we used to
babysit them you know i mean make sure
they don't
drive and go running in the um driveway
and [ __ ] you know what i'm saying so
i've been knowing him as but then he
kind of moved away for like
four or five years and when he came back
i think um shawn mack brought him in
that was my little brother rest in peace
you know what i'm saying
he brought him in the studio one day i'm
like i got mitch it in here man come on
bro taco finish
tripping y'all got him hanging with us
and like nah
he went in there and and dropped the
verse and i was like damn
i was like oh [ __ ] i'm ruchi [ __ ] ain't
you feel me i'm like okay
and then ever since that one verse he
just been boom boom boom boom it's
grinding
and then um i feel like when the homie
sean died he um
he just just that [ __ ] just for the
battery
with me when he passed it just had me
like
i ain't gonna say like under a rock but
i had no motivation right right
to do nothing you think it affected him
the other way infected him
if it affected him like different he
just the soul of him just came out and
he was like both of them rapping on
songs
wow so he had the aggression the the
the um the the word play
and everything all in the song
everything that shawn had and he just
added
fuel to the flame you know what i'm
saying he and it's just
a work ethic got him to where he i'm
saying where he at now
who i mean you're really tapped in with
the scene out here who are some of the
young
la guys that you're a fan of that you're
you know that you're [ __ ] with
i [ __ ] with slum lord you know from the
jungles uh infant
um i like key riches
out of compton um
who else i've been listening to i [ __ ]
with chike
um
yeah off top that's that's like my
playlist right do you feel like um
because i feel like uh historically in
la
uh you know because of politics a lot of
uh
there it wasn't oh big sad i [ __ ] with
snakes too big
sad we always talk some [ __ ] um yeah but
but
you know there's always politics in l.a
right yeah and i feel like
throughout the years la's probably been
one of the more segregated uh hip-hop
communities
when it comes to like just the
perception of people not like doing
you know like not [ __ ] with each
other all the way like we always hear
like atlanta everyone's together they're
all wrong
but i feel like this new jersey look
like that [ __ ] out of town but the
[ __ ] don't be together though
right but they'd be getting on each
other's records
and you know it's crazy but but um in la
this new generation it feels like
there's a lot of camaraderie
you'll you'll hear like one take jay
with ruchi or you'll hear like
you know um i just feel like i always
hear everyone on each other [ __ ]
yeah now it is like the the new excuse
me like the new
like it's different but it's different
in a good way i remember when i was
growing up
like [ __ ] to even bust through you had
to be
snoop dogg affiliated you know i mean
whether you was a gang member or not
blood or a [ __ ] or whatever you had to
come through
that channel to get on you had to come
through that channel or the dre channel
i mean the snoop dogg is the dre channel
no no no that's some
that's some crazy [ __ ] cuz i remember
talking to nipsey in like 2010 when he
was not [ __ ] with dre
me but you still he went to snoop dogg
no no but but but i remember like
think about i mean you were part of this
nobody in my arrows
glasses malone think about but i'm
saying that
oh no i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about there was that whole era
of la rappers yeah
that just kind of got shunned by the it
was oh by the way it was glasses
yeah it was it was j-rock it was uh it
was
it was nipsy yeah you know rocket you
know
yourself like there was like all these
ele there was like this scene in la that
almost like
the gatekeepers quote unquote you had to
go through like a game
in order to go to go through snoop or dr
dre
to be like you know i mean to get
solidified that's why other
[ __ ] start going out to
gz and rough riders and g-unit and [ __ ]
like that because it was like
wasn't nobody here trying to put nobody
on yep
and then i think the only thing i mean
obviously dre i mean
kendrick's a perfect example once that
draco sign happened just [ __ ] changed
i'm not saying kendrick wouldn't have
been great anyway because he's all-time
great
but like that but yeah when the drake
show went to dre it was like this
like he became great though it was like
this yeah so was that before
good kid mad city no that was no that
was after uh that was before section 80.
it was before or after section 8 before
oh okay yeah it was before section
remember that key club he had that
watching crying and [ __ ] yeah yeah when
game
game officially passed the torch it was
uh and then he had that watch out for
detox freestyle
yeah which was crazy but then he just
went out of here he just became
the elite after that yeah and it's crazy
because at the time it was like like i
was real tight with nipsey at that time
and it was like
nipsey was putting in so much work and
game props the game
because game gave a lot of people looks
at that during that time like you know
what i'm saying that
i don't think so you don't think so i
mean i know game
pl he put he put uh nip on the road with
him on the lax tour
and j rock and j rock like i'm seeing
like
you know he had glasses on on on black
wall street and [ __ ] like
i just think that was on black wall
street yeah he was i mean he was a
yeah oh i didn't know that yeah
see glasses put me on a word what the
people that
that that solidified me out here when i
was trying to
have my cds on me was these are people
that i still talk to to this
i talk to glasses once a week we argue
about rap music mitchie slick
shout out to mitch you said rock and mr
fab
these guys was the ones that like
mitchy slick would be like hey bro this
is you need to be here we'll bring all
your cds
oh you can't i'm gonna fly you out you
don't believe it i'm gonna fly you out
oh you're gonna stay at my spot in the
bay and
record with these people and dinner
glasses was the one i come to my show
i ain't doing no show unless this one
head was glasses dj
hey um yeah 211 need to be on my show
too when everybody was paying
remember all you used to do all that
when you have to pay open up yeah no uh
211
if he not behind me he need to be the
second one after that person need to be
rapping whoa whoa mr fab oh come
whatever
whatever you 211 need he got it and i
was nobody bro i was just
in wood gangbanger you feel me with a
chain you know what i'm saying and i
could barely even rap
glass is one of the realest man yeah
glasses was pulled up in
my hood in the dirty bentley jumping out
with a pro club on like yeah what are we
doing he's like hip-hop skip bayless on
twitter though yeah that [ __ ]
got some wild hip-hop opinions
yeah he do though oh and another person
that embraced me was and terence martin
so these shout
martin these are the guys that was his
studio tour two doors over
for a while that was where he used to be
at yeah yeah see and these are people
that embraced me and
in my beginning you know i'm saying that
i that
i don't forget this type of [ __ ] you
know me so can't nobody tell me nothing
about none of these people mitchy slick
was
uh still is a very underrated i mean i
love strong arm steady all that [ __ ]
yeah
like i was listening to his music before
i even met him and he became like i
would call i call him a big homie you
know what i'm saying
like i don't think he gets enough
flowers man no no you don't but
i mean in my book he do because i i tell
anybody
these people that i just named are the
guys
or my guys that that pulled me in when
[ __ ] weren't pulling nobody in yeah
everybody was like no no you
you'll figure it out type [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying but didn't have enough
to be like i'm gonna put you on right
right but they were i'll push you over
there trying to help you
yeah and when nobody trying to do that
especially back then like that was out
yeah back then i feel like it was
definitely out yeah so
um yeah it was just
yeah that timing was different too
because l.a have a sound
you know i'm saying they had no sound we
everything was out of town
you know what i'm saying and yeah i
think that yg and that mustard
and no i think definitely i think like
that kicked it off
for the new la i think yeah it was that
that
what was that 2010 2011
2012 yeah really we was on it but really
it don't matter what we was on
it just matters what everybody else like
when you leave
because it seemed like it was like game
was the guy in la
for for a point in time where it felt
like long time only guy in l.a yeah
nationally yeah and then once that yg
mustard thing happened it was over but
it took out of town [ __ ] to
be like that oh yeah that's la we've
been listening to that [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying for
at least four years before that it took
for them to be like my [ __ ] my [ __ ]
with uh all right homie uh richard
and jeezy on there and it took jeezy to
be like yeah this
this him r-i-p-r-i-p and then just to
set the whole [ __ ] on fire and that's
what it is you know that era when it was
like tiger was doing rack city
and i'm different bro i'm different to
change when he did that
they had the beats that were like and
that era just
just said it set the tone for it and now
we have the new la sound where you hear
some [ __ ] and you'll be like that sounds
like some la [ __ ] but it's like
now it's all mustard legal star
re-rocked you feel me like
100 so anything that was hot back then
ain't gonna be really like hot right now
it's just re-rocked and remixed and
you know what i'm saying you put the
just like the trap [ __ ] yeah
you know me i remember when uh lex luger
yeah yeah
it was hot and lex luger kicked off that
sound and that was awesome
and now it's mike williams metro booming
and they're all sons of that that early
yeah it's all re-rocked
you feel me so that's some crazy [ __ ]
yeah well look your album is out
um you already got a video out with uh
the ruchi yeah i got two videos out um
i got another play with me uh quincy
white and freddy
shout out to quincy quincy's dope he's
been around for a long time too yeah
yeah yeah he was a real part of that
uh that time in two yeah yeah what was
his old rap name
dub dub yeah yeah that's right oh my god
dub
dub and then we got um and then i got uh
the one i
top down i just put out uh cyprus did
the beat
shout out to cypress man my guy cypress
uh
and uh yeah with ruchi and freddie on
that also you know
shot by my boy hd tay he shoot movies
and your store man shout out your store
the level up store you know y'all can
follow follow uh the level up store
where's that instagram
just so everyone knows sitting ella next
to the service spoon in inglewood
okay yup yup how is it in being in
englewood now that it's quote unquote
being gentrified a bit with the
arenas and [ __ ] uh i'm really like two
miles away from legit
from the arena so they ain't really go
up on me like that you know what i mean
but
uh i mean it can't hurt the property
value right yeah yeah nice
it's smooth though i like it you know do
you think like um
like do you look at that as like a
positive thing because there's like a
good and a bad side to it yeah i mean
you know
um i look at it now and it's you know
back in the day it was just spray
painted everywhere [ __ ] was raggedy
[ __ ] hanging out on every
corner in the street and now it's just
cleaned up they didn't turn
[ __ ] into um lax adjacent and all that
little [ __ ] westchester
you know looking type [ __ ] but it's
still inklewood but
you know you it's like out of towners
like you know like white people walking
down the street
like dogs and [ __ ] is it's just crazy
this is different but it's for the good
like how long
this shit's supposed to be [ __ ] up
right we're supposed to be out here
in the [ __ ] up environment if y'all
got the money to fix this up let's do it
do the clippers get any brownie points
for being there
like because obviously everyone hates
the clippers and everyone loves the
lakers but like
do you like yeah yeah i should be mad at
the lakers because the bikers ran
ran off and left yeah they did and they
had the staple center downtown i don't
even know where the clippers supposed to
be playing at though
i think they're in englewood they not
this year no no no no not this year no
no i think i think in whether the two
years or next year they're going to be
in england they're supposed to be
yeah um doing the uh century and prairie
i
heard sure i mean it's crazy because i
i never thought like i i didn't get the
whole
like clipper hate in l.a until i moved
here and i'm like yo people really do
why i don't even know why they hate the
clippers they don't [ __ ] with the
clippers i'm like dawg no matter how
good these are so i like the lakers
i'm a lebron hater on court you feel me
i [ __ ] with them off court but on court
i'm a lebron hater because i root for
the underdog and then they just be
yeah so i'm a i'm a laker hater and a
lebron hater
i've been a laker hater for years but
i'm a lebron lover so i had to
both sides of me doing that cause i go
for the underdog though man all y'all
man lebron lebron the lakers the lakers
like
lebron my favorite player but i'm a sons
fan so my whole life i hated the lakers
so when he came to the lakers i had to
come to a business decision to like
put my lego head away damn i say you
know what
lebron's on the lakers now yeah as long
as he's on the team i'm gonna just root
for him
damn i'm gonna wait to play all the time
i'm gonna go up on you
you got chris paul um at the of the suns
i'm finna start going for the sun
hey we good number two in the west right
now how is it we you were supposed to be
a laker fan
i'm not a lego fan i'm a lebron fan but
if the sun's in the lakers play i'm
[ __ ] with the suns oh okay okay
i've been a sense you should be a sons
fan think about how shitty the suns have
been
so like for a long since night so all my
like
i mean now we had that run with nash and
amari and you know we was relevant
up until about 2010. but um
i've just i've attached myself to lebron
yeah the last 15 years or whatever yeah
so it's like okay
i love the suns but we really ain't been
[ __ ] for granted nothing too damn good
i just i just i think he's the underdog
in the sense that like he's playing in
michael jordan's shadow
so he might not be the kobe shadow not
michael jordan's show
he's surpassed kobe what oh come on
man what is he talking about nobody
could never be
good as kobe bro i think kobe better
than jordan
bro let me let me let me tell you why
you're wrong let me tell you why you're
wrong
all right shaq leaves you remember
and he went how many more championships
but let me explain let me explain
it was two no he played he won one more
what the hell
no no how many kobe win wait wait okay
shaq left kobe for two years
couldn't get the lakers were the eighth
seed yeah so the two years after shaq
went to miami
the lakers were the eighth seed okay
this is when he quote unquote had no
help
okay he never had wait help what you
mean what
kill o'neill no i'm saying he okay
afterwards he never had help pal gasol
and andrew bynum who's the all-star
center andrew bynum lamar odom sixth man
of the year did you just say andrew
bynum
can we check out um andrew andrew bynum
was a bum when he left
he was a bum when he was there waiting
like you're telling me he wasn't a
starter he was a seven
five [ __ ] sinner with that being
seven
five and 400 pounds those two years
yeah that kobe had literally nobody
right yeah he couldn't even get the
lakers out of the first round of the
playoffs
now rewind lebron in o5
had eric snow was his starting point
danielle marshall was the starting small
forward and he was like 15.
people and he took them to the finals
against the spurs
yeah with no help colby finals at 0-5
yeah they didn't go to no championship
bro they played the spurs and the spurs
waxed them yeah but they beat the
pistons
in the eastern conference finals and the
year before that the pistons won the
ring
damn so my thing is but in the
east he beat the defending champions in
the eastern conference finals
no they beat the lake the pistons beat
the lakers in the finals the year before
but they had a different team though no
they did it huh
it was the same starting five i'm
talking about chauncey phillips rip
hamilton no
the pistons beat the lakers when they
had gary payton
carl malone and they did yes listen i'm
a basketball fanatic so
with that being said when lebron has had
no help in his career
he's always been in the [ __ ]
mix how many championships he won though
listen he go he gonna be fine because he
got all the built teams
so he was good bro he went against the
warriors the greatest team ever
assembled
well he had a symbol team too
hold on let's let's get to the warriors
because the warriors these are all
genuine good players they wasn't put
together kevin durant
i think kevin durant had one time he
played for them one time
he played for them for three years for
three seasons
but he played twice when they won he
played three years with him though
he ruined the nba for three years he
ruined the nba
kd damn now that's a put together teen
they got in brooklyn right now
that shit's crazy super salary if they
don't win the [ __ ] ring
you feel me like god damn how are they
getting this money from
bruh it's crazy they just got on the
market lamarcus aldridge and blake
griffin
like how did they do that where are they
getting this money from because he got
bought out and they signed him for the
veteran minimum
oh y'all already played he playing for
free pretty much
same thing with blake got paid off he
got paid here they paid him out yeah i
don't know but yeah shout out [ __ ] i'm
finna go try to get on that team like
yeah let me let me play
i got i [ __ ] with kobe but he ain't
[ __ ] lebron come on man yeah he was
just waving that's the one thing i think
that we
we were unfortunately never privileged
to see was the kobe lebron finals
oh yeah yeah but see it's the age
difference though nah but you know if
you think about those years
it was the the year it should have
happened was the year that magic
beat the cavaliers in the eastern
conference finals and that was the year
that
kobe played dwight howard in the finals
and the lakers won
that was the year it should have been
lebron versus kobe yeah the other year
it was oh eight and that was when the
the
celtics had the big three that they
assembled when they got reality
and kg that team took the cavaliers out
because lebron had no help
yeah but that's the one thing i wish we
would have saw was kobe versus lebron in
the finals
we never got that event cause if you
think about like
jordan we saw all of the jordan battles
we wanted to see going up
like he went against magic in 91 yeah he
went up against the pistons in the
eastern conference finals three years in
a row
he went up against the celtics he went
up against all these dude like he had
battles with
like he went up against barkley in 93.
yeah you know what i'm saying i was that
was when i was a [ __ ] sons fan
oh yeah yeah yeah he didn't even go up
but he went up against barkley but
he didn't win that game you know who won
that game john paxton john [ __ ]
paxton i hate that [ __ ] right
there
i'm saying i had the whole i was like a
kevin johnson fan kj
what kj dunked when kj look at my poster
right there look back there that's
john's on elijah
oh that elijah one was like one of the
most i had the crackhead on your team
richard dumas that was my year though
right richard
was smoking rocks as a rookie ballin
though it's starting
oh my god starter on crack oh girl crack
my man was a rookie smoking crack
he was real though he was out there
serving they had a team bro
they had hey they had a team i ain't
never been to phoenix before but i was
i don't even know how i even became a
phoenix son hey we had dan marley dan
marley danny ainge yeah
um um um oliver fat ass danny man danny
manning
yeah oh they had a squad with barkley i
don't know who the big man was
we had uh mark west oliver miller uh
yeah oliver miller oliver nick nick um
hold on
who was shooting them threes uh dan
marley was was
was lights out it was a um
rex chapman yeah i had rex chapman
though too they had a squad
yeah oh look man yeah thank you for
pulling up
go get the album go check out the store
mastermind out now you feel me 211.
yeah that boom all right perfect